what mistakes did you make early
discussed in your live podcast that
could have progressed you further hmm
yeah I think there's just some real big
obvious ones wasted a bunch of time you
know you waste a bunch of time when
you're young you think you got forever
and you waste time and whether it's
doing stuff that's not productive
whether it's going out get drunk
whatever dumb things you waste time
doing whether it's just just wasting
time and and you know what look I'm not
saying don't have fun in your life
because that's wrong answer to if that's
too extreme but what I am saying is I I
sometimes I had a little too much fun
sometimes I wasn't focused on the right
thing so wasted time is number one
wasted money wasted a ton of money on
dumb stuff and I'd say that both of
these are wasting time wasting money
those are like the two biggest mistakes
that I've made but I would say that the
root of those mistakes is that I didn't
do a good job of connecting the future
to the present Yeah right
you just don't when you're young I
shouldn't say that when I wish I was I'm
gonna put a universal blanket of being
dumb on everyone even though you're not
your head pretty hard alee over there
because that's wrong yeah we see a lot
of people do this right a lot of us we
waste our time we waste our money and we
don't connect what we're doing right now
with what's gonna happen in the future
and that is not a good policy to have
what we want to do and what I try and
instill with kids with my kids with with
kids that I talk about on the podcast is
I want to connect what decisions are
being made right now with decisions that
with the with the end state that you end
up with in your future so if you take
advantage of your time you're gonna be
in a much better place if you save your
money you're gonna be in a much better
place if you invest your money properly
you're gonna be a much better place if
you train and you treat people if you
train hard you're gonna be in a much
better place if you treat people
respectfully and you build relationships
you're gonna be in a much better place
hmm
if you do the opposite of those things
you're gonna be in a worse place if you
treat people like dirt you're gonna
it'll come back to bite you if you waste
your money you won't have it
if you waste your time you'll run out so
I think the biggest mistake really for
me was that I failed to connect the
present to the future the only ways that
I succeeded in that early on was through
luck hmm
like I joined the Navy and and and I'm
very lucky that I did because I was
immediately building my future even
though I had no I wasn't my intent
doesn't mean I bought a house that was a
great what I wanted to what did I buy it
for I wanted a place to live
what did I end up with an incredible
investment enough to buy another house
that one was a little bit more
intentional okay wait a second if I
owned another house and I was just
talking about this with a friend of mine
it was like that I was explaining when
and he remembered when I got my second
house and I was like in my mind Donald J
Trump the real estate landlord like
master Yeah right someone was gonna be
paying me rent you know and and I had
another house that I was gonna live it
mm-hmm
so that was a that was when I started
making this shift where I connected the
present with the future yeah so what'd
you do today is directly correlated to
where you'll end up in the future that
that is in echos favorite sort of thread
of this entire podcast disser is playing
the long war and it took me too long to
start fighting a long war that's what
I'll say that better will say the
biggest mistakes from my early life yeah
and really in a way I mean they could be
viewed as not even really mistakes I
guess this is more of just sort of
that's the way things happen because be
most times we figure these things out
later in life be when the long game
starts to materialize because when
you're early in your career that you
only the short game is sort of there and
then in a way to actually know at the
end of the day no because even as a
little kid you know the long game you're
familiar with it a little bit because
like you ever had and you had to save
your money for something
Optimus Prime boy you know something
like that and they said you gotta save
your money for it yeah and no you save
your money
you know that's playing the long game
yeah as a kid you know it's a kid
version so it's kind of the same thing
but maybe it's not as intuitive you know
when you're little when you're big when
you're grown
no yeah 1792 difference it's the other
fear the weird thing is like someone has
to tell you but like we just talked
about sometimes when people tell you you
still just don't listen to them yeah
yeah you know people say hey you should
really do this and you go yeah whatever
that's for you
yah yah banana yeah it's for you one of
my one of my uncle's friends won the
lottery years ago like in the 70s hmm
and he won one of those big lotteries
mmm where he got money every year you
know you could take the lumps on her you
could take the payments the payments
he took the payments yeah well won the
lottery right literally won the lottery
won the lottery
mm-hm and so the payments lasted 20
years well when you're 22 that's that's
forever Yeah right that's forever yeah
and so my dad was talking to him talking
this guy that won the lottery and now he
was at like the nineteen year mark yeah
and guess what he had done with all this
money spent didn't he invested in real
estate that he by start companies what
do you think he did with this money
spent it yeah he bought car and whatever
that ten thousand you know like dated
girls and went to bars and went out for
nice dinners and did that for a long
time yeah and so my my dad says hey you
know they're talking about it he says
well you know my you know this is the
last year that I'm getting my monthly
payments for winning the lottery mm-hmm
and my dad says what are you gonna what
are you gonna do when the payments
aren't coming anymore hmm
and he says I'm gonna win again
so yeah that's planning right yeah in a
sense we all kind of and ya know it's
not obviously but man that's friend one
the life but that tends to go like that
for lottery winners yeah apparently the
lottery winning isn't a big like
happiness no it's bad yeah ends up being
bad because life is a long long game and
no matter how you play it the long game
is the one that that shakes out you know
so if you're over you're playing the
short game that's that's why you lose in
life if you play the short game all the
time yes and the people who play the
long game they did all you gotta do is
play it you don't even have to dominate
it although I'm not recommending not
trying to dumb and I'm not saying I'm
dumb right nobody necessarily after yeah
you could come in shoot second to the
last place but if you're playing the
game you're gonna be doing good along
you when you come in second to last
place in the long game you still just
beat every single other person that's
playing the short game you know you beat
them all yeah and it's not air and
they're over there looking around like
what just happened yeah how is who
you're so squared away yeah but it's not
that complicated you know I mean it's
not easy it's not easy you're wired to
plays how'd it go deep on this on that
last warrior kid podcast yeah oh yeah
this this death it's like a little short
term you have need to get over the short
term gratification man and that is the
one of the biggest lessons a kid can
learn is that my actions today will
affect my future and it's hard to
convince some of that it seems so
distant you know like the future seem so
distant you know when you're young yeah
I was having another discussion with
someone that a parent and and there was
a level of frustration mm-hmm that and
it's the typical level of frustration
from the parent which was you know the
kid has a lot of potential but they're
like they you know not training the way
they should be and not working the way
you know all that and all that stuff and
what I tried to explain to the parent
was that the potential that you're
telling your kid that he has they do not
even come
and what that means it is not a it is
not a it's not something that they can
understand it it's completely intangible
like even when you say oh you keep
practicing this you could be the
champion yeah this means you might as
well say if you keep practicing this
Ebru bobbers you probably yeah yeah it
means nothing to them yeah so that's
what potential is to a little kid a
little kid doesn't understand it yeah
and so yes you try and convince him I
mean you try and explain it to him mmm
but what I recommend is instead of
trying to explain to them this massive
concept of what their potential is you
try and give them some short term
rewards that lead them in the right
direction that are are supportive of the
long game but they're easier mental
connections for the kid and this the
same thing applies to employees as well
right you know or you get a young young
employee that's you know they're not
thinking they could be the the regional
manager right they're just thinking
they're just happy to be here yeah but
you're you're looking I'm gonna ask you
know this is sharp kid could be could so
you might not say look one day you're
gonna be the regional manager in 22
years think about that when you if
somebody gets hired on us whatever and
you say one day you're you could be the
regional manager and you could make
whatever this big chunk of money they're
looking at you gonna homeowner they're
to be here at we don't I'm only gonna
have this job for six but whatever yeah
so what you want to do is just tie
something a little bit closer to them to
their reality
yeah of hey here's where you could get
here's where we the bonus program works
here have you seen this you can make an
extra whatever yeah and it's gonna move
them in the right direction long game
but they can comprehend it immediately
yeah that's my recommendation should
even just compliments and encouragement
are good little micro rewards for those
short-term like are they over my kids
once again we can't abuse them yeah an
abuse you know friendliness with our
children we use cheerleading yeah right
we can't abuse cheerleading with our
kids and everything that they do is
beautiful right yeah no that's as
beautiful
piece of art that you just created what
is it beautiful yeah no yes sir it's
like that that's not good yeah that's
not good but you're just talking about
abuse and the other thing is the other
thing you have to be careful with this
you know you're telling your kid like
well you know you're special
yeah or you're you're so perfect right
you know yeah and so you know yeah so
this can get better yeah I get it your
marginal just know that no yeah and what
I mean encourage me in in in compliments
it's like if they do something good you
compliment that good thing that's
essentially it
yeah like anything you can throw out too
many and you can throw out two little
really because the the the fulfillment
or satisfaction of receiving that
compliment isn't big enough for the work
that they distill be like man I want to
do those 100 I mean my daughter do 90
burpees the other day why 90 did you
just want to withhold - no I'm working a
century I'm working her she didn't get
to 90 and say hey Dad you do whatever
you want I'm getting 10 more watch this
no I'm getting do a hundo well here's
the thing she's done that before but not
with 90 so I'm working her up
I started it from like I was like a when
she was real short I'm fine in time it
how are we gonna recognize improvement
because we're gonna get to the number
first then we go for example got it so I
mean that's the story I mean it's not
like you know my life's mission of
course it's just a fun little thing that
I do
but if sounds fun yeah sure but so if if
I'm like hey hey you're super strong
they like that or my kids like that when
you call them strong so every time they
do something like exercise or something
like that and they do a good workout or
whatever I'll say how strong they are or
how strong they are looking or being or
whatever but if that feeling isn't
enough to constitute that super hardware
like if I over push them like a 90 given
where we are with burpees with her she's
not raised she wasn't ready for 90 at
this time so did she cry she no she
ain't
thankfully she'll cry no shame she'll
cry I went for a run with my youngest
daughter this is a while ago and I don't
know how she old she was at the time but
I was like okay we're gonna start
running cuz I wanted to improve her mile
time at the school I said okay you want
to prove that my own time I know how to
do it here we go
so her mile time was weak and I said we
can get it better so the first run we
went on I'm not kidding she by the time
we got one minute deep she had tears
welling up in her eyes yeah and and you
know I said hey just keep going but that
the the point of saying this is my when
I try and give children especially my
children or any children compliments I
try and compliment their hard work yeah
as opposed to your strong or your smart
and what I say is you really worked hard
for that and look at this great result
because what it makes them realize is
that the great results come from hard
work and guess what that is the truth
because we all know people that were
incredibly smart incredibly strong
incredibly talented and incredibly
gifted and they didn't do anything with
any of those things because they didn't
understand that they had to work hard
even if you have all that skill if you
don't work hard you're not gonna get
anywhere yeah dang that's a good little
so addition lean towards complementing
the hard work yeah and that's what you
really want to see yeah let's face it
let me ask you this and this is a tough
question would you rather have someone
on your team that is extremely talented
or extremely hard worker you know of
course it's easy we all want to say well
I take the talent cuz we can make the
person work hard but that's actually not
true and and the real talent the best
talent really is you get someone that
just knows how to grind and work hard
yeah like that's good and that's gonna
be much more valuable then hey this
person super smart or hey this person
super strong occasionally you get
someone like GSP yeah George st. Pierre
who was
wait Alan tada modalities and was a hard
worker you know that person becomes a
world champion yeah sometimes you get a
world champion that's just there because
of hard work sometimes you get a world
champion that's just there because the
talent occasionally you get someone
that's both and they're usually sort of
a stared more dominant yeah like a
dominant jet yeah that's true and that's
good or do I started to compliment the
hard work I I personally like both I
like to especially with my son like
being strong and stuff he really likes
that you know so he'll it's to the point
where like if you help him do something
he'll get mad at you kind of get madder
yeah which I kind of like I don't know
where that's gonna lead you know but I
like that currently um so he he has that
sense of pride you know we're being
strong is a good thing I know that's a
little there's nothing wrong with that
so yeah but man if you add the hard work
part of it because being strong is
essentially a result you know yeah and
he doesn't obviously - yeah it's really
gonna be easy connection for you to make
because it's hey you're strong and
that's cuz you work hard yeah because
the minute you say you're strong because
you got your own yeah cool I'll just sit
over here beat you what do you got yeah
it's true and and when you especially if
you don't recognize the hard work part
of it you know and you just think you're
as a kid you're just rolling around
strong you're you're basically you
you've reveled in the results for so
long where it's now when it's hard work
time it's kind of like wait I'm not used
to that part of this they say that can
happen too they call them gazelles in
Budds these are people that like really
fast good athletes yeah and but they
never lost before yeah and yes they
started getting beat down which you do
get beat down and they lose they can't
handle it mentally yeah oh yeah so yes
sir that is um that's real